When it comes to serial child killer Albert Fish.
The adjectives to describe as in humanity hardly seem strong enough to proved
perverted,
deviant degenerates.
He was all of that,
but he was much more the crimes he committed.
Fill the heart with rage.
Well,
the taunting letters he sent the victim's families make you wonder how a human
being could possibly be so cruel.
And this week's biographics,
we venture into the sordid life of Albert Fish and fair warning.
This episode,
it ain't pretty
how Molten Howard Alba's fish was born on May the 19th,
1870 in Washington DC.
His father Rendell was 75 years old when he was born,
being 43 years older than his mother Ellen.
The old man died when,
uh,
but it was five years old and the children,
they were placed into an orphanage and the orphanage Albert's sang in the choir.
He was also subjected to merciless beatings by other boys as well as even staff
members.
The physical pain of the beatings in the wings.
He Games a realize gave him a sort of sexual pleasure.
He would get erections midway through a beating,
which would bring ridicule and further torment from the older boys.
Albert spent four years at the orphanage when he was nine his mother secured a
job and took her children back.
Two years later,
I began a relationship with the telegraph boy who introduced him to a range of
depraved practices including drinking urine and eating feces.
He also took to hanging out at local bathing rooms so that he could have watched
young boys getting undressed.
At around the age of 11 Albert's fell from a cherry tree and suffered a serious
concussion.
This would result in constant headaches,
dizzy spells,
and to pronounced stutter.
In 1890 he moved to New York City with his mother.
He would later tell the police that he became a male prostitute at this time,
but this has never been substantiated.
He began working as a painter and to paper hanger.
Is there anything ese 90 is,
according to his later testimony,
he regularly molested young children preferring those who are under the age of
six.
He also enjoyed writing obscene letters to women who had placed personal ads in
the newspapers.
In 1898 Albert's mother arranged for him to marry a 19 year old girl by the name
of Anna Mary Hoffman.
They would go on to have six children at the same time.
He maintained sexual relationships with a string of male lovers.
One of them took into a wax works museum during which time now,
but it became fascinated by a model of a dissected human penis.
It was this experience that developed in him a fascination with genital
mutilation and castration for the rest of his life.
He would insert needles into his scrotum and penis and audit to achieve sexual
satisfaction.
In 1983 fish was arrested for embezzlement and sentence.
Do you sing sing prison?
During his incarceration,
he regularly had sex with other men off to his release.
As children recalled that his behavior became increasingly bizarre.
He would regularly hear voices and declaims that he was receiving messages from
the Apostle John.
On one occasion,
his oldest son,
Albert's Jr.
I saw him standing on a hillside with his arms out stretched and he was
screaming,
I am Christ.
He was convinced that he was being directed by God to castrate little boys,
psychiatrists,
which later diagnosed him with a condition known as religious mania.
The children would also recall seeing their father flagellating himself on the
back with a nail.
Studied paddle.
In 1910 fish began a sexual relationship with a 19 year old intellectually
disabled man by the name of Thomas Ketan.
Fish was working away from home in Wilmington,
Delaware.
He brought Kevin back to his room and the two engaged in sadomasochistic sexual
acts.
Over a period of days these acts became more and more like torture with fish
inflicting all of the pain.
He took a cat into an old farm house with the intention of killing the buy and
dissecting his body in the auntie Millie cut off half of Catherine's penis
before leaving him to his own fate.
In 1917 fishes,
wife left him for another man I wish was left with six children to raise on his
own according to fish and it took virtually all of the possessions that the
family owns and it was from this point.
But his paranoia to come new dimensions is children.
Once found him,
wraps up in a carpet since he would encourage them to hit him on the bed.
Buttocks with his nail,
studied paddle.
However,
none of the children ever claims that their father physically abused them.
It was around this time that Alba began experimenting with cannibalism.
He started by eating raw meats,
which he would also serve to the children,
and then this escalated to human flesh.
In 1919 fish intensifying as criminal activities abducting,
abusing,
and murdering young boys in and around the Washington DC area.
It's typical victim would be black or intellectually impaired.
Does he believe that the police would be less inclined to pursue the
disappearance of these children?
He develops the skill of luring children away by offering them gift since
appearing to be exceedingly kinds and flattering towards them.
In July,
1924 fish came across a young girl who was playing alone on her parents,
Staten Island farm.
He had convinced the goal to go off with them to pick rhubarb.
When the mother arrived and scat him off.
It's still his obsession with the eight year old girl forced him to return and
he tried to sleep in the barn.
Once again,
he was discovered this time by the father and he was once again and chased away.
Another botched abduction occurred when he invited two young boys to his
apartment for lunch.
While he was preparing the food,
the boys waited in his bedroom.
They began play wrestling on the bears and then they fell onto the floor there
they saw under the bed fishers self-described instruments of hell,
a meat cleaver,
a hacksaw,
and to knife frightened out of their wits.
The two boys took to their heels running past fish and right out of apartments,
fishes,
modus operandi of snatching the unimportant and the unmissed was thrown into
chaos when he unwittingly abducted and murdered Francis Mcdonald,
the son of a stash and island police officer.
The eight year old was playing ball on the street with four friends when fish
who had been hanging around for hours called the by over when his friends down
to see where Francis,
well,
it's both here in the stranger had gone when France has failed to return home.
His father sent out after him.
After scouring the neighborhoods and questioning the other boys,
he kept hearing about the gray haired man who had been hanging around.
Then he telegraphed to police headquarters the next day.
A massive search was underway throughout Staten Island's.
Eventually though the body of Francis Mcdonald was founded by three boy scouts
under a pile of branches and leaves on a railroad property.
All of the clothing below the child's waste had been pulled from his body.
It was apparent that he had been viciously sexually assaulted,
fissured,
finished him off by strangling Francis with his own suspended us which way wound
so tightly that they appeared to be a part of his flesh.
Within minutes,
more than 50 police officers were surrounding the body.
The next day,
the case was given the highest priority with 250 officers assigned to us.
The boy's father,
Arthur McDonald,
was transferred from Manhattan bracing to Staten Island so that you could
personally work on his son's case.
The autopsy on Francis Body revealed that he had been eating raisins just prior
to his death.
The police concluded that this must've been the lure that the killer used to
pull the boy away.
The terrible condition of the body caused the coroner to conclude that the
attacker could not have been an elderly man.
It's a cause that degree of physical damage.
He must've been in his prime.
Hysteria,
swept through the state and daily reports came in of sightings of the gray man
in the weeks following the discovery of the child's body.
Dozens of men were questions with several being arrested,
but they to released hopes for an early resolution to the case and vanished as
the leads just dried up with public interest in the case fading the dead boy.
His mother made a desperate plea to the public.
Help us catch the monster who killed our by.
Help us find the gray man.
On May the 25th 1928 18 year old Edward Bud placed a one line classified
advertisements in the New York Wells newspaper in an attempt to find employment.
Three days later,
an elderly man knocked on the front door of the boat apartments on 15th Street
in Manhattan.
He said his name was Frank Howard and he was replying to the situations wanted
ad in the paper.
Edward Bud's mother invited him in and sent his younger sister Beatrice to fetch
brother from next door.
Edward seem tons up with his friend Willy and toe.
Howard offered both boys jobs on his farm in Farmingdale Long Island.
He then told them that he would return on Saturday and drive the boys to the
farm the following Saturday.
The boys weighted excitedly with their bags packed,
but Mr. Howard,
he never turns up.
Instead say telegraph was delivered,
which told the boys that how would it had been delayed and we'd come for the
boys the next day.
He turns off in the early afternoon on Sunday,
just there's the family had returned from church.
He was invited to stay for lunch.
It was sitting at the food table that Mr. Howard got his first view of grace,
but the pretty ea roles was dressed in her best Sunday clothes.
The old man was immediately smitten,
beckoning grace over to him.
Shoot,
moved to a mother who nodded her assent.
Mr. Howard told grace how pretty she was.
He then asked if she was a good counter.
When she nodded,
he pulls from his pocket.
It's the biggest one of money.
There's anyone in the room had ever seen.
He laid the cash and the coins on the table and asked grace to counter from
grace,
counted out $92 and 50 cents of the conclusion of which Mr. Howard rewarded her
with a 50 cent piece and told her to go and buy some candy.
The rns system again,
the mother nodded her approval and the list will go left the room happy.
It was then the old man informed the buds that there had been a slight change of
plan.
He had to attend his young nieces birthday party that afternoon.
He would return for the boys that evening.
Then just as he was leaving,
he turned to Mr [inaudible] said that he just had a thought would they allow him
to take young grace to the birthday party?
He said it was going to be good fun.
There was going to be lots of food and games and plenty of children her age and
of course he would have her back by nine o'clock this is bud was hesitant.
They didn't even know this man,
but he didn't seem exceedingly kinds and he clearly loved children.
Before she could answer,
husbands had made up her mind for her saying that the girl never got out and it
would be good for her to have some fun for a change.
This is bud ones,
isn't know where the party was going to be.
How it answered that it was a to assist display,
so the hundred 37th and Columbus Avenue,
the buds didn't realize that Columbus street ends it a hundred and 10th street.
Say the address did not exist and so it was the young grace bud was dressed up
in a spring carrot and gray hat with blue streamers and headed off up the street
with the gray man.
Misses Bud stood at the door and watched them disappear around the corner.
It was the last time that she ever saw her daughter.
The buds weighted with growing alarm for Mr. Howard to return with grace.
By Monday morning,
Mrs Bud was hysterical with worry.
Edward was rushed off to the nearest police station to report that the goal was
missing.
A short time later for detectives arrived at the bud home to question the family
about kidnapping.
It was big news,
the life of the country.
The case was unique in that the whole bud family had gotten a long and detailed
look at the so called Mr. Howard.
Thousands of flyers were printed with a detailed description accompanied by a
photo of grace.
These weren't distributed throughout the u s as well as Canada.
As expected,
there were a rash of false sightings and leads that went nowhere,
but then a solid lead finally emerged the telegraph office.
Well,
how would it send the Telegraph to the buds from was identified and intensive
search of that area then found another clue,
a food basket that how would it left at the bud's house was identified and the
man who had sold it to Howard,
it was tracked down from this.
It was deduced that the kidnapper was a resident of East Harlem,
but from there the trail that went cold despite a raft of letters and
confessions coming in,
nothing panned out.
Then in September,
1930 there was a break in the case.
Police arrested a 66 year old by the name of Charles Pope.
Pope was held in custody for three and a half months and then put on trial and
you need to be found not guilty.
In November,
1934 the still grieving parents of grace budge received an excruciating league.
Gruesome letter,
which police later confirmed was from Albert Fish.
Read in pass.
I grabbed her and she said she would tell her Mama first.
I stripped her naked.
How she did kick,
bite and scratch.
I choked her to death.
Then Casa in small pieces so I could take my meat to my rooms,
cook and details,
how sweet and tender her little ass was roasted in the oven.
It took me nine days to eat her entire body.
The police were able to compare the handwriting in the latter to the telegraph
notes that they had recovered years before.
It was immediately obvious that they were written by the same person,
but it wasn't the letter itself that finally brought Albert fish down.
It was the envelope in which it was contained,
printed on the back of the envelope flap where the initials and why Pcba police
were able to track it down.
So the New York private chauffeurs Benevolence Association,
they found out that the janitor at the association had taken a bunch of
envelopes home to his rooming house at 620 to Lexington Avenue.
Just activists descended on the boarding house.
But we're frustrated that no one there recognize the description of Mr. Howard.
But then the janitor remembered that when he had taken the envelopes,
he had not yet moved to Lexington Avenue.
He still had been living at east 52nd street.
When a detective showed the landlady your description of Mr. Howard,
she immediately recognized him as the elderly man who had moved in.
When the janitor had left,
the officer asked to see the man's signature and the register pulling out the
letter that had been sent to Mrs,
but he could see that the signature was written by the same person who wrote the
disgusting latter.
The man had signed his name as Albert h fish.
The detective discovered from the landlady that Albert fish who would move it
out a few days earlier,
received regular support checks from his son.
On several occasions he had asked the landlady to cash the checks on his behalf.
It just so happens that the check was due any day.
Insufficient said that he would return for us.
The police now set up a 24 hour surveillance of the boarding house.
Yup.
After three weeks there was still no sign of fish and the surveillance was
reluctantly called off.
Then on December the fourth the land's Lady of the rooming house phones,
the police do inform them that fish had just come in and inquired about his
check.
In fact,
as he was still that the landlady was told to stall him,
she ushered him into a room and gave him a cup of tea.
Minutes later,
a detective walked into the room and looking at the frail old man on the couch
said,
Albert Fish.
Fish was momentarily taken aback,
but then he reached into his vest pockets and boil down to razorblades and held
it out.
Threateningly that is active.
Quickly closed in and grabs the old man's risks and twisted.
The blade fell to the floor.
Then the pathetic killer slumped back down on the couch.
Looking down at the man had been hunting for years.
The detective simply said,
I've got you now.
Alba fish went on trial for the murder of grace bars on march the 11th 1935 the
night before the had managed to extract a chicken bone from the CPA had been
served.
Sharpen it to a point and proceed to repeatedly stab himself with it.
When a god heard him moaning,
he rushed in and managed to take the makeshift weapon away from him.
It was reported as a suicide attempt,
but it was simply a means of satisfying is deranged sexual desires.
They're out of the 10 day trial,
fish maintained and in different attitude.
He sounded slumped in his chair often with his eyes closed and appeared to show
absolutely no interest in what was going on.
One report that describes him as resembling a corpse insecurely props in a chat
that events readily admitted that fish committed the crime.
It was that contention.
However,
the tea was legally insane at the time of the killing and that he remains that
way as he sat in front of them.
The prosecution on the other hand set out to prove the opposite thought he was
saying that he knew the wrongness of what he was doing and therefore he must
answer for his actions.
The prosecution called a series of psychiatrists as witnesses.
Each of him stated that the defendant was seen though suffering from a whole
host of psychotic conditions.
In the end,
the prosecution did persuade the jury that fish was saying they found him guilty
of murder in the first degree.
The sentence was execution and the electric chap at sing sing prison.
One of the jurors later revealed that most of the jurors actually felt that fish
was insane,
but they felt more strongly that he was deserving of the electric chair.
Albert Fish's last day on earth was January the 16th 1936 he was escorted into
the Execution Chamber is 11:06 PM he cost his hands together in prayer as he was
lowered into the chair and strapped in the leather cap was fitters and
electrodes were attached to a skin as the current surge through his body,
Albert Fish's body jolted backwards and veins in his neck,
bulged and his fists in voluntarily clenched.
Then his body went limp.
The Monster.
He was no more so.
I'm absolutely not going to ask if you enjoyed that video,
but I do hope you found it interesting maybe to illuminate it a little darker
period of history for you.
If you did like it,
please do hit that thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos twice a week on this channel,
and as always,
thank you for what,
hmm?